hi there Steve Kaufman first of all I
want to you know let you know that a
video that was put together by Benny the
Irish polyglot where he grouped a number
of so-called polyglots and got them to
sing a song and we all contributed to
the wording in different languages that
this is now up on his YouTube channel
and I think it's a phenomenal initiative
I salute Benny wholeheartedly for coming
up with the idea and then putting it
together in such an excellent fashion I
suggest you all go and have a listen I
have a minor role in there where I i we
were all supposed to pick two languages
to sing in and sort of right up those
verses you know sticking to his central
theme and bearing in mind that who we
had some very good people his speakers
of some of the main languages that I
speak like Japanese and Chinese and
stuff so I went for Swedish and
Cantonese as my contribution I'm not a
very good singer he also asked us to do
something that was typical of where we
live so I had one of my buddies a hockey
thing there shoot a video of me is
skating and towards him ah and so then
Benny was able to kaleidoscope all these
different contributions into a wonderful
wonderful video and wonderful in my view
because first of all it demonstrates it
we are we can all speak different
languages which is a wonderful message
hopefully encourages people to start
learning languages wonderful because it
had people from many different countries
of many different backgrounds speaking
languages that were not their native
language except for the intro where
Benny sings in English something
everyone sings in one or more languages
that are not their native languages and
someone pointed out with people of
different ages of course male and female
and the world is a very connected place
we're sharing this time on the planet we
should all get along well together speak
each other's languages enjoy each
other's company and so that's kind of
the main message you know we don't have
to use skype we don't have to the point
is I think rather I mean I think it's
very topical it's a skype me maybe
whatever it fits the tune but the main
message is get out there and learn some
languages connect with people you will
be very happy you did so I'm going to
leave a link to Benny's video in the
little box here below the video and i
encourage you to listen to it I salute
Benny I mean we may have had some
disagreements over whatever it was I
can't even remember anymore but the guy
is a ball of energy and his main message
is language learning is fun go at it so
I fully support many in this in this
venture and yeah it's it's I think it's
a wonderful wonderful achievement hats
off to many thank you bye